always told me anything and I don't have
a concern I'll just wait and see
Mikey works on Monday keep working go
attack the Miami Dolphins and plan on
getting our first win next week s Jay
Gruden after yesterday's 33 to 7 loss to
New England Patriots and I feel that way
all the time as long as the keys working
I don't know your wife keeps giving you
on I don't know what she's thinking I
work at the house so I never leave so
it's kind of hard to get rid of me
talking about coming in here oh I've got
my little thing that I use every day and
there was one day where it didn't work
and it's like well you know this is how
it goes down it's about time this is how
it goes down and it's how it went down
and I just can't help but wonder because
the news broke so early this morning it
didn't reach out to Jay to make sure he
doesn't even bother to try to use the
key this morning because it is over
right but look we we felt this one
coming I don't want to make light of the
fact the guy's lost his job
no ordinarily this is where I'd say he's
gonna be paid for the balance of his
contract but we know how things go in
Washington if they can find any
plausible way to not pay you they'll try
to not pay you're like the DECA crazy
video that Mike came out the weekend
incidentally came out on Friday same day
he said quote always the starting
quarterback not Dwayne asked a little
weird
what coincidence that one and let me
tell you the organization is upset and
resents the insinuation that they're in
any way responsible for it they're not
upset apparently that someone was trying
to smear their head coach
there was no anger about that it was
just that there was an insinuation that
they were in some way behind it but the
circumstantial evidence and I'm not
saying that they did put that out there
the circumstantial evidence invites
speculation reporting examination
definitely fishy cuz it all came out on
that day where Gruden defying the
organization's love of Dwayne Haskins
goes with Colt McCoy who's just been
hanging around for the last seven years
yeah and then after the game they had to
know that after the game on Sunday he
was gonna be out for him to be out so
quickly after yesterday's loss to the
Patriots they had to know going into the
game that this is it for Jay Gruen I
would think so I would think they're
realistic enough to realize that they
probably were not going to beat the New
England Patriots barring a miracle or
something like that and yeah you know
again you know you said it I feel bad
for Jay Gruden I think he's done a good
job there in Washington it's you know
I'm not gonna sit here and say he should
have been coach of the year a few times
or anything like that
but I think some of these circumstances
and players that were put around him on
that roster were not his doing and he
did the best with it and of course this
year has just been a disaster from the
get-go whether it's been Trent Trent
Williams you know some of the rumors
we've heard over the last few week with
Dwayne Haskins and all of that and they
just have not played well and of course
got their butts whooped yesterday Bill
Callahan reportedly the interim head
coach he's the guy who took over for Jon
Gruden when John left for the Buccaneers
in 2002 and Bill Callahan took the
Oakland Raiders to the Superbowl that's
he did that first year right and of
course guys like Tim Brown had some
conspiracy theories about Bill Callahan
throwing the game by not changing in
nogales I don't think you know a purpose
I just think it was dumb well you know
change any of the audibles Jon Gruden
knew exactly what the Raiders were gonna
do but Callahan has shown he can coach
and I don't think this means he's gonna
be the guy in 2020 we know how it works
for Dan Snyder there's somebody out
there already that he's in love with
that he's gonna try to bring in for 2020
and we'll start to get some some hints
some reports as the season continues to
unfold that will point us in the
direction of what they're gonna try to
do next but they've been trying and
failing for 20 years
to turn the team around and yeah I mean
what they do what what is what does the
you know what how attractive is the
Washington Redskins job right now I mean
we all talked about the dysfunction I
mean you know I do I wonder where that
all you know just kind of plays out and
looking forward because there's things
you like too I mean hey offensive lines
got a little potential okay there's some
young talented guys there you the
defensive line certainly talented and
then you have a young quarterback who
you know of course is it's always a big
thing so will coaches be attracted by
that no no maybe not now at a minimum
this is a job that you only take if you
have no other head coaching options that
they're not going to get into a bidding
war I don't think the guy who's at the
top of the a list and who's got two or
three offers he's not going there right
the question becomes has it
disintegrated to the point where it was
like the Raiders 15 years ago when Sean
Payton said no thanks I
wait for a future opportunity a year or
two from now I don't want to touch this
one has it gotten to that point and you
know at some point we have to ask the
question how much longer was Bruce Allen
gonna be the president I think seems
fair to him somehow avoids all scrutiny
right all scrutiny yeah and he has
positioned himself where he's close
enough to the football operation to get
credit when things go well when they
rarely go well then again they were five
and two last year through seven games
then Alec Smith got injured and it all
fell apart but when it's time for
accountability and scrutiny that's when
Bruce Allen is able to say hey I you
know I'm not the coach Yeah right I'm
not the general manager though he's in
charge of that team and it feels like
Daniel Snyder wants to keep him around
until they solve the stadium situation
but it feels like that's a long-term
play and are we talking about seven ten
more years of Bruce Allen just to get a
new stadium even if it means the
football organization is going to
continue to be dysfunctional yeah well I
mean I'd at the very base level I just
think about it and go gosh I mean it's
gonna be hard to ask for a new stadium
as the case if the organization
continues to be dysfunctional and show
no progress on the field so yeah Dan
Steiner is gonna have to some decisions
to make there about Bruce Allen and
really they're the whole the whole
organization and in its entirety
it was Patriot fan takeover at FedEx
Field on Sunday Tom Brady said after the
game it felt like a home game yeah and
that's not a good sign if your fans are
not showing up right you got to do
something and trying to put together the
money to build a new stadium is
secondary to trying to rebuild the fan
base and create the kind of excitement
necessary to leverage that into a new
stadium that somebody else is going to
pay a significant portion up
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports